hey everybody what's up happy uh friday
it's nice out life is good and i want to
talk about
talk about sorry i'm getting excited
already something i think is really
quite interesting i'm always
fascinated when there's a big story over
here but the real story
happened here and when we look back and
say huh we were all focused on this
but this was the real real issue at hand
and i think what happened
just a couple days ago ironically i
actually made a video about this two
days ago
but i did directly to facebook and it
didn't load so facebook
your video thing is hurting my feelings
but what facebook is going through right
now i think we all know
tons of privacy talk lots of things i
think for me on this issue
i respected people's privacy is very
important i understand however
facebook is going to adjust i mean do i
have to mention
beacon the ability to adjust and the
far majority shocking far majority that
either
don't know or don't care i think is not
going to make this the issue that so
many
people think it is now it could be wrong
i mean sometimes these things snowball
out of control and it can't get crazy
but i think facebook has shown
several times the ability to iterate
change move and adjust to these kind of
situations
what i think is far more interesting and
far more important is the five-year deal
that they just signed with zenga
that you know people that bring you
farmville and other social games the
biggest
social game player in their ecosystem
the deal is signed for five years
xanga's not going anywhere and more
importantly
the entire deal circles around in my
opinion from afar
around facebook credits because facebook
credits are going to be used in their
games
their platforms and will spread through
everybody else that's kind of the big
dog
even though i see the farmville numbers
are starting to slide they do have an
ecosystem and a platform
to build new games in rocket launch new
products
facebook credits becoming standard and
working and when you look at the profit
margin that facebook's looking at
taking 30 percent so xango sells 200
million dollars
versus virtual goods that facebook ends
up with 60
million dollars on this this is going to
be a financial explosion
for facebook facebook credits goes
longer and farther deeper into
getting into brands doing things where
they you know incentivize people with
credits
i think this zenga deal the ability for
them to make a deal because they need
each other in a big way but for facebook
this is an outrageous victory
i think credits has the potential to be
completely insane
and i think many of us will look back at
this video i'll look back and be like
wow i was younger and better looking two
years ago
but i'll also say man i was so right
because geez everybody was talking
privacy but this little announcement not
so little to some areas but kind of
little in the scope of
what's being talked about about this
five-year deal that they've made
locked in the partner they needed in my
opinion they'll probably need a couple
more
that really established this platform
that is going to be a monetizing
and cash cow for them that will allow
them to go to a completely
next and scary scary level
see ya